my name is alexander primack
i did my phd in the university of
southampton i've been studying computer
science how large societies behave well
be using lots of tricks
lots of graphs and sometimes to process
the data you need to have
interesting data structures to work with
and in this talk i'm going to
briefly introduce you to the most
interesting data structures and some
tricks
which are very useful this is going to
be quite introductory and
maybe intermediate talk with some code
examples you don't need to code anything
i'm going to show you the code and
to seek for deeper answers you you
should be following maybe some
references i'll give you later
so probabilistic data structures and
approximate solutions
so why first of things
often approximate transfer is good
enough
and you don't need to have
spock or spook spock actually from
star trek who was always giving you the
very accurate answer which sounded
always ridiculous
you sometimes want to know and estimate
and
if i'll transfer use a precise figure in
millions how married peoples are there
in the uk
uh that won't be that informative all
you need
is an order of magnitude and so actually
sometimes it's good enough so and
most interesting we need to trade
accuracy for scalability or speed and
this is
what all the structure is designed for
you should always bear that in mind that
you will lose the accuracy so all these
message tricks have a margin error
good ones will also give you bonds
on that error and actually this is the
first indicator if you are
starting a structure and a method
which doesn't have any bounds if it's
error or confidence
you should be better giving up of that
and
they're very good to analyze streams of
data when you have like
infinite theoretically infinite streams
of data and you want to do something
with that
without storing them so catch
um typically you will get good results
expected value is good
but there is always chance of bad worst
case behavior
and yeah we'll take a look on some of
those
and you should be always thinking if you
remember
law of large numbers from course of
statistics
which was telling you that the more you
sample
the more accurate your estimated mean
will be
and so never use anything like
probability or approximate for small
data sets it just you will be getting
this worst case behavior all the time
it's not for that so it's always good to
know what it's not for
um so approximation it's a very simple
thing what we are thinking about
approximation it's when we need to
calculate an exact
answer and for example here
um i want to get an average of very
large array it's uh
uh random
10 000 randoms of uh numbers between
zero and 1800
so average should be somewhere 1400
right this
will be the whole set uh this set is
going to be
a tricky one we're going to remove eight
bits from each number
and so we actually will going to reduce
the size of the set
each number will reduce by 10 000
bytes the whole data set and the last
one it's going to be five percent sample
actually this is this set is already
uniform because i drew it from
random generator so i'm just taking a
slice i don't need to make a choice
and here i'm taking averages this one
i'm adding those eight bits back
i removed two to power eight
and uh on results you actually can see
that error rate
is very manageable and we are getting
very
close to those 40 000 and i would rather
say that
this somewhere in the margin of error
very close to
that initial data set so as you can see
actually we can deal with
five percent of data set and being
perfect
people sometimes forget that we can
sample data and it's always
important for you to remember that when
you test it you sample
and you test your code in the sample but
actually you can do that in production
as well
and there is no need sometimes to deal
with hadoop and
people right now just throwing money
because they can
and some sometimes wrong so
uh sampling data and just we raise this
issue for approximation
this is like classical interview
question
get some samples of an infinite stream
sample infinite stream have you ever
came across with this question
no how you would approach it any ideas
no i want to get a fair sample
of an infinite stream this stream is
infinite actually
the real question which uh friend of
mine been asked on
google interview i believe it's not been
asked anymore
and it has very nice and precise answer
firstly let's think that that that isn't
infinite it's just
very large so we're not dealing with
overflowing anything that we have to put
ourselves into context
any ideas
every five second good but i want to
have
k k samples i want to have ten elements
so every five seconds if i'll be picking
an element i will have only last uh
ten second it's now
actually it's nice idea i like it no i
didn't do it that way but
actually it can work i believe
but the thing is that's uh there will be
problem with
what have been offered that we taken
distribution exponential distribution
which describes a
wait time in poison process and we draw
according this distribution so
more or less will resemble that we are
randomly picking cars from a traffic
it's what it was offered but there is a
problem we will still
be ending up with lost cars with the
last few cars that we picked up
according to distribution
and so when this stream moves we'll
forget our
previous elements
good good just just okay it's just
well i think it's time to develop it to
some code sample
so it's going to be very simple
okay sampling
i'm taking excuse me
here it is i'm taking the same
large large vector of ten thousand
elements
and i'm sitting the sample it's a trick
i need to some to have something in the
sample
so i need a one and it will be gone as
soon as we'll get those 10 elements
and then i'm just looping over this
stream it can be streamed just
here it's a vector and i'm assigning to
each
element an index
this is a virtual index it's
non-existing index which is random
number
to every new element i see next one i'm
assigning
random index and this can be sorted
according to this random
index and i'm taking a look in my
sample set my sample set is actually
this index
which is randomly assigned index and
an element out of set which i want to
sample
and i'm taking a look on maximum
index in my sample
if it's lower than randomly generated
numbers and i'm taking this
element into into my
sample and if i got already too many
elements or
more than i had i'm just deleting the
one with a maximum
random number so i made virtual index
it's very very simple trick and very
efficient
works and uh
yeah sure you can write code trickier
make it nicer
but let's have you sample and you
you can deal with infinite stream of
data which you don't need to store
because the usual answer for people this
is a catch why it was question infinite
people want to store and then somehow
index
uh randomly generate indexes and get it
but we can actually create an index on
fly
uh so next things which we'll be going
to talk about
these are actually probabilistic data
structures that
we'll be dealing with samples or somehow
describing our elements
what are they really for are they
usually for optimization is they use
less
space than uh original data structure
but they are very specific each of those
data structures
is designed for specific use
they require sometimes higher cpu law to
access it
they require sometimes higher cpu load
but
we always trade for space and general
we reduce number of operations that
we execute so even if
an individual operation of accessing
element checking samsung gaze element
is more expensive on average it's much
cheaper and
consider that cpu is cheap right now
we're limited by brand ways we're
limited by
memory they're stream friendly
as a sample because we can deal with
data without
storing the whole data set we just can
aggregate it somehow
it can be parallelized in many cases
we can calculate those structures on
different computers even
and later merge them it's a nice
property of some
structures and most of them are
well established in academia and they
have controlled error rate
and they're very important when you'll
be dealing it and you want to
i'm just reminding once more you want to
be sure that structure you're choosing
is you can trust it check if it has
confidence on its performance confidence
rates
if it doesn't maybe just trick a
structure
or maybe nobody investigated then just
do maybe imperialist
well some check empirically
if it will help you but you should be
cautious if it doesn't
so the first thing that you should know
is hash function
you must have heard of many of those
you heard uh crc ssh md5 i'm sure
right so we just
remind ourselves what are those it's
when you take a key
you take a some hash function and it
somehow magically maps
into hash so key which
came on entrance can be of arbitrary
length it's very
very important we can take there a film
of four gigabyte and just take a hash
and later verify
and torrent network if what we
downloaded matches to
what i requested by comparing those
hashes
and uh
and we get a fixed length of message
on outcome this is a hash code simple
function
it's one way function we cannot get from
a key
back to to the message and
i'm sorry from the message which is hash
back to the key
it's used quite often in encryption
and you know that a lot of those hash
functions are used like big crypt right
now
but those are not we're going to talk
about today
and they have collisions it's also i
think you know if you
deal with any of those some of those
different elements may
map to to the same hash and well
this is where we became in probabilistic
and approximate
in all these structures so some code
sample
so how the simplest hash work
works it's a lose-lose hash it's known
hash algorithm is quite old
by classical computer
science it's when you're just taking a
string on the entrance
and
summarize all its characters as
integers and that's it it's called
lose-lose
so here we have two different hashes for
this
function well this function
is prone to the problems one is being
tested
it has lots of collisions and this is
very bad we want a hash function
which uh as randomly as possible
distributes its hashes
so we will have less and less collisions
so there is another one very classical
one
dj b2 it has magic numbers and that's
how
in general all hash functions look they
do some magic transformation with a key
shifting by 5
getting the prime number in and again
multiplying
string character
number and it works much better actually
and it gives you
fairly good distribution if you're
actually input
your keys are fairly good distributed
well
here is you get some output and sure we
have lots of
built-in python we don't need to develop
the will
mg5 ssh5s are standard and many of those
you can find if you
install openssl but there is a trick
with that all these functions
some of them are were designed for
cryptographic and
you are not be using you shouldn't be
using cryptographic functions for
data analysis some of them are like
ssh are very quick they perform quite
quickly quite well
but in general uh modern
like b crypt they are very slow on
purpose
to prevent people uh then decrypting by
basically scanning through the whole
possible keys and getting a message
and getting your password cracked using
the salt they
may be stolen so we want something
that's actually very very quick
and sure there are many of those
one of those i'm going to show is murmur
sounds
interesting it's
this one looks like hash function
nothing nothing to to you to worry about
so
here we'll take a look better on results
so cryptographic hashes are not ideal
seek for hashes if you do any data
analysis or you
trying to use hash algorithms use
something like murmur
it's uh tested right now on this is test
from somewhere from stock exchange
uh one of the most popular
hash algorithms for this uses against uh
lose-lose which i showed you on three
different data sets it's lower case
dictionary of english words random hueds
generator and numbers sequence of
numbers
and murmur is quite good it gives you
six collisions on
somewhere like several thousand hundred
of words and here are sample collisions
uh kind of differentiate for example
from storm bound well
other functions are as you see actually
nodes are far behind maybe some of them
are slower on this case maybe on this
case are equally
similar but clearly loose loose has
insane number of
uh collisions it's 20 well it's like
a quarter of data set is in collisions
so um so why murmur actually when we to
take
all those hashes from the whole
dictionary and it'll be like
very long then we'll take a hash of each
word put a very long vector
it's like one axis and we'll then
cut it online just to make it nice
square and
we'll light a pixel where we had a hash
we'll get this hash map very nice
hashmap color is
just to make it nice it's not mine
disregard color but the most interesting
and it's very visual
you can see that it's kind of random
and you feel very happy with that then
you throw much
more sophisticated data set you set a
sequence of number and it's much harder
for hash algorithms sometimes to
differentiate very similar strings which
are
just one character different and what
happens with
weaker like djb2 which i showed you in
that
code example you see actually there are
gaps
and it's clearly that those
multiplications and shifts
which we've seen happening as a code
quite simple one they
aggregate hashes around some clusters
and this is bad so we clearly see that
half of our hash space isn't used and we
have
potentially much higher number of
collisions
just to give you feeling what's
happening inside of the hash algorithm
but not always we want to have hashes
to be different we sometimes want to
for two different strings to return
similar hashes
and this is where starts interesting
because all those things i believe you
know maybe something new will come it
will be coming
and it's called scientifically locality
sensitive hashing
it's when we have a similar objects
we want them to have similar hash to
compare
without actually comparing field to
field and there are algorithms including
text search algorithms which are using
these strings
and this is one of the simplest one it
brings
document that you want to compare these
hashes were developed in order to
differentiate between
documents in early search engines right
now they're using similar
algorithm but much more powerful i
believe it's alt vistas this one
they had like lots of servers which were
crawling websites and they wanted to
know that
actually this is the same website maybe
something changed between two of those
different crawls but
we actually got the same page and so
this was the first stage
to compare hashes and they were
developing similar things
they were taking document splitting into
feature
feature it's actually chunks of text
think of that like we take every three
characters
and this is the feature then we hash
this feature
then we in this case weights are all
once
and then we take uh multiplying them by
these weights
and we just see if bit
is up it's minus it's b is zero it's
plus
and we're getting just a sum sounds like
ridiculously simple
calculations if one minus weight if
another plus weight and we're getting
when we adding all them together
some function sure it's not going to be
randomly distributed because we're doing
quite a little of permutation
and should be there in other document
this one bit has
changed only one simple element will be
changed and this is
hash function uh it will be very close
to
the one with other bit there i'll show
you how it looks
this code it's a bit yeah
and it's going to be harder for me to
show you on this screen
it was nicer in my large resolution
but at least you'll be able to see
something uh there are lots of
firstly uh implementation python you
don't need to implement those things
just google for them
and even in just you can install any is
almost by pip
this one i took from pip i just a bit
simplified it to
fit it it just initializes hash object
on this screen
and and just calls function build
by text using some values which we
uh well maybe we should care this is the
number of uh
features we're chunking our input
value we're chunking it for 64 features
it's a regular expression to
tokenize it and here we tokenize
features using that
regex and then sliding through that
content
and for each feature here we after build
these features
we basically performing the function
you've seen on that
algorithm we're taking the hash function
and doing very simple permutations using
some tricks
uh
believe me it's just a parallel
version of what you've seen on this
slide and then you have very simple
distance
uh how to compare distance between
hashes it actually has been shown
have you heard of cosine distance how to
compare distances between vectors
okay i'll show you in later on another
slide how it looks like
but basically we check how many bits are
different between two different hashes
and it's been proven to be very reliable
distance
and so here how it looks so
you clearly see that inputs are quite
different for those
hashes similarly despite there are only
few changes in those lines
these somehow close but they're
different
still very different from this one
despite inserting only a few spaces
and here let's see how they're comparing
distances
so distance zero between comparing it to
itself
distance 12 when i started to type
in teenager wave and
and some i don't know some distance
when i wrote completely different uh
phrase these distances
don't have a metric it's just abstract
values you you have to burst in mind and
it's experimental way and it depends on
hashem algorithms which you use
how to set up the threshold of
comparison
so there are a few of those locality
sensitive hashing algorithms
and they are very powerful i love them
you
don't need to go into your database you
can just compare hashes
and be sure that you got the same
document but it's going to be more
interesting do you know how google
images works
locality is sensitive hashing well not
really but
if we to implement it so this is a paper
which
implements quite well side paper
i think it's 200 it's not 22. and this
is a sample
of the hauser hashing algorithm
detected and grouped together images
so they've designed the hash algorithm
which
for images with similar features
provides the nearest distance
and then they're just measuring distance
between different hashes not between
images
which is computationally
quite cheap they were able to cluster
these images and
show their accuracy quite scientific
believe me
and you can find those examples you can
find numerous examples about that
from my experience what i've been
playing with which was quite interesting
we were designing another hash function
was the supervision of my curator on
bachelor he was using us as a
testing devices so we were calculating
for him
hashes of contours of images
and we were coming of different
ridiculous uh
hashes in order to verify one against
each other
sometimes it just trick you way of trial
and error so
our professor just threw a bunch of
students
and he made like real genetic algorithm
which student will came up with a better
hash to compare two different contours
that worked it says this is a whole
problem was to recognize
number plates and we were
given images which had already contours
of the numbers
and we the whole idea of the project was
to develop
the most efficient algorithm for
character recognition which can work
even on embedded microcontroller
i was a bit back in time that it was
right now we can put raspberry pi i
don't care about that but
sometimes you have 50 million images in
your product database and you want to
find similar one
which is it takes us back
so next are finally
real probabilistic data structures those
that were before and we were discussing
before those were tricks and uh
basics you will need to understand to
progress without any of those
so the first probabilistic data
structure and
as anest will follow is designed for a
particular purpose
this one is for membership test
we are given a very large stream of data
and we want to get only only unique
elements for example
and we want to check against our
existing database have you seen it
before have you seen it before
and that would be very costly if we to
consider that that's
a database of images for example so we
can calculate a hash of image
not similarity hash but more more very
randomized hash
and then with these hashes we
will be doing the following tricks
uh we will populate a bitmap
of length of amm bits which is
usually rather long which i've been
using are coming up to megabytes and
for very large data sets 100 megabytes
but consider that that data set
is several terabyte it's it's a
trade-off
and then i'm taking several different
hash algorithms or
quite often hash algorithms say hash
algorithm can be
feed fitted with different seeds to
provide different hashes
it's it's being done in order to improve
quality of this
algorithm and according to this hashes
this hash
yields for us some answer for example it
yields us
three different numbers which indicate
where we should be looking at in our
bitmap
and when we insert something into a
bloom filter bitmap which is initially
initialized always zeros we just
check all these cells to which were
appointed
and flip them to once and that's it
this is a problem we can only write to
bloom filter we cannot delete
elements from blue filter there are
extensions
but in classical we cannot delete an
element from
from bloom filter and then when you
want to check element against blue
filter you're just calculating these
hashes
for this element very similar way and
just checking back these elements
if at least one of those bits
is turned to zero this means that
your element that you are checking is
definitely not in this bloom filter not
in list
it's guaranteed but if they are all at
once
it's probably in the sat you probably
have seen it
this is where probabilistic kicks in as
you've seen before we have problems that
uh
hashes collide and even despite we had
several different hashes they will
collide collisions
often and um
if you insert it into small bitmap a
very large number of elements you
basically
flooded it always once and whatever
you'll be checking against it
it'll be saying that it exists there so
there is a trade-off and you have to
calculate the number of
bits you need basically the size of
bitmap a number of hash functions
to use and with a very grounded theory
you came up with a probabilistic
guarantee that this filter will work
uh with this error rate for this number
of elements
so why we need them
actually we're using them all of you
using them if you're using databases
you're using them
for example clearly in hbase and i
believe in other databases
just it's not transparent in hbase you
can manually set it up
it has bloom filter before going into
very slow storage to retrieve your
element a check exams checks against
bloom filter
if this element i've seen before
and it's being populated while you
insert something on the database
while database is being re-indexed uh
sure there will be a collision and maybe
balloon filter will mistakenly
say that this element exists in database
and you will go into database
but this is it will be one percent of
channels in 1990 percent of chance
you will do zero disk seeks restoring
all hashmap of your database in like
several megabytes in memory
which sounds like a lot of improvement
so
this is one of the use the second of the
use that uh
i think i'll i'll be showing you here
sorry it's previous i shouldn't be
creating very long
snippets i'm sorry
excuse me
oh it used to be f11 i'm sorry
i'm messed up so
here is a blue filter uh all these
libraries implemented sure and see if
they just compiled with siphon or just
directly see and you plug in as a
library
doesn't matter you're using python and
you're just benefiting of efficiency of
this library behind it
there are poor python implementations
which i don't recommend to use because
well
it'll be dramatic difference in
performance
but here's how it works you populate
bloom filter
and this bloom filter implementation is
very neat you just
uh tell it cardinality your expected
cardinality of your
set you can approximate it just
probably infer me how many unique
elements you're going to see and what's
your accepted error rate one percent
and it calculates for you all those
hidden variables such as the size of
this
hash map and the parameters hash
algorithms to use
and then you can store it in the file
and you can read it from a file and just
sometimes very great for example i'm
just throwing all unique dictionary into
this structure and checking and it
instantly gives you replies
um so if you want to get
back to that a random example
of getting unique numbers
i have random vector of numbers 500
elements here they random
i have proven by showing you twenty
first ones and then
i'm taking bloom filter which is very
small i know that actually those random
numbers
i have can have only twenty different
elements i'm being optimistic
always i'm saying maximum cardinality
thirty
one percent accuracy and i'm just
storing all those
i'm looping through those random numbers
if it's not
in the set up to the set
this function actually this method odds
element to assad
and yields true or false if it has seen
this set
with this element before in this ad if
it's
was before uh wasn't before i just been
added to this list and i'm sorting
and hooray i got from 0 to 19.
so yeah i got all unique elements from
a random vector well usually you're not
going to use this
for this need what i've been using for
is
you can actually peek into a structure
it's just a huge hashmap but for some
reason my ipython
hangs when i'm trying to do it what i've
been using this for
i have a list of i have logs
which are full of users just cookies
and i want to sample that i don't want
to
deal with well it's like terabytes data
for months several terabytes of data
it's like ridiculous
i want to have a fair sample i'm just
taking them all by their
uh uids and it's problems that they have
them in different logs
those users been doing different actions
and they were storing different places
and then
then want to merge those logs
and it's going to be tricky if you are
to do this on
merging one data set for example i have
a sample of
a million of users and i'm trying to
merge it against
several terabytes of data i need somehow
to just
loop through so i'm putting all these
unique users into bloom filters this is
tiny utility
i've written and
it just scans through
input
if this file was given it just picks up
a file existing to which i
already stored all users and then
if it's present in the element i'm just
outputting it and with this i can just
very quickly
and actually i can parallelize this very
easily
to to sample users or
maybe i want to get only unique bot
names from our log files
this is a way how it can be done quite
quickly
well blue filters are very well popular
and there are many extensions to them
numerous extensions and for example
people are extending them by letting
them forget information this is the
question of uh
if you're dealing with streams of data
and you want to discard all results
then people are trying to
basically you can do the same by having
two bloom filters and just
one's the one full and the other half
full just discard it
you'll have just sudden drops but there
are
extensions for that uh the problem is
that
nonsense is actually giving you ability
to always correct
identify that element
has not been seen because of those hush
collisions
and this is interesting saying how you
can use blood filters
and how they are used on very large
scale people which are doing
metagenomics and this is very
interesting for me i've been listening
for their talks just from curiosity
they analyze genes of
lots of bacterias it takes whole bunch
of bacterias
well it's hard to do it's a sample from
the t
they do dna sequencing on the whole
sample
and they end up with a short
strings which are representing bits of
their dna sequences which are all mixed
and they're
just one species being split into
thousands of those chunks and we have
100 species and
then you end up with a soup of
those chunks but
this is like a tricky thing
what they do they put all this
information
as a graph into bloom filter
because they are not able just to
reconstruct that graph
for meta genomics problem even for with
computational power we have just because
it
is becoming too expensive for them
they dealing with some margin of error
so what they do is it just takes this
chunk of dna and they
agree on the sample window we may think
this is a word
for characters and they take four
characters
and map it to the fifth character
and they just put it into blue filter
this
five character then they actually just
in
dna are limited to four characters the
test
then they discard the first character
and add four different
characters in the front and test which
of them exists in the blue filter
and so they move step by step trying all
different direction in this graph
development
just in genetics you have only four
different bases so it's quite feasible
to do
and here are the tasks they did they
basically
this is each tiny element of the circle
is a sub string which predicts
another character of next substring and
they're just basically
lots of overlapping substrings this is
when we setting accuracy to
the highest level and we are
learning a loop of those genetic bases
you can then recreate them very easily
because our accuracy is extremely high
should you add margin affair one person
you already
see that it's not recovering
sequence correctly and this is somewhere
on margin of only 70 to 60 percent error
and it still is able to
discover well circle dependency which is
amazing and quite a lot of research done
in this
and uh just fascinated by them
let's move further so uh
it's all in streams and uh we already
checked if element of the stream we can
filter streams with bloom filter
uh but how to count distance elements
well blue filter doesn't provide this
information
there is a extension for that which can
help you but it's very inaccurate
so there are special structures for that
we have infinite state of data
again how many distinct elements are
there you'll be surprised but actually
it's similar to coin flips how many
times
uh if i record coin flips how many times
actually i flip the coin
and i'm going to illustrate you this
it's simpler than you think just
illustration will help you a little
so we are flipping lots of coins and
longest run of zeros it actually
correlates uh
i have intuition here when i'm along the
front and heads
uh of these coins are very rare if you
just
to flip a coin and turn time
in raw you will have a head but the
longer look the more likely
you will be able to see one and there
was a video of a guy who actually
thrown on a camera ten times in the raw
head of a coin
and was like all amazing on the internet
it's like not fair coin but actually
he wrote that he was throwing coin
continuously for nine hours
and just that at the very end when it
happened
i know they were filming it for some
scientific purposes
so these long runs are very rare and
decorated with how
many times how many coins you have
played
so how it works
so the first function just
generate coins flips nothing the second
function
is just calculates this is in the
sequence
number the maximum number of uh
zeros that are where are following each
other i
just goes in the loop just initializes
my counter go in the loop
if it's zero count plus one else just
drop the counter
and check if the counter meanwhile was
more than maximum and update the maximum
it's very simple
and then
you just uh this is actually how it's
being executed
those two functions are bunched punched
together
and this is a very interesting stuff
begins when we
do this hundred times it functions that
uh
were about it was to aggregate around
large number of
experiments and we plot distributions
so we 100 times through 100 coins
here's how histogram looks so
how often we can see
excuse me
so what the length of uh
zeros maximum lengths of zeros uh that
um we
have seen in that variable that
distributed according to this
distribution which is a little bit
skewed and it's actually
maximized somewhere near six
and it's most interesting that
we expect this to i'm sorry something
didn't print well here i'll
rerun this bits of code
excuse me i'm being confused by my own
slides
sometimes happens
if you uh to
remind yourself that actually we did a
hundred run
and you will just take a logarithm base
two from 100
you're magically getting this same
number which means that actually
you need to take the longest number
of zeros you have seen in the sequence
take two to power of this number and you
will approximate the number of coin
flips that you had
this is for a longer
run for 500 runs for 1000 coins
and this time estimate is even closer we
see it's been estimated somewhere around
nine and we expect it to be somewhere
around nine theoretically
so this is very simply how this
coin phillips calculation happens but
you just noticed we
uh we can calculate with this anything
because we can
take any data we can convert into this
random flips of coin by taking hashes
out of each element of this data
and assuming that those hashes are
randomly distributed it will be
approximation of those flaps
so and this is known as cardinality
estimation problem
and this is also this
algorithm is a basic description of
which is called
a log log cardinality estimation
we hash each item into bit string
count trailing zeros in bit string
and intuition is very simple
it's very rare you see lots of zeros
ahead or at the end of a binary number
but the longer you see and considering
that in random numbers it's more likely
you will see
lots of leading or trending zeros and
we're just taking this
number and remembering it
and then we're just estimating
cardinality by
uh how many distinct elements we had by
taking two to power of those
leading or trailing zeros and those bit
strings which were representing
uh each element
there are problems with this and
problems are that uh
estimated or not accurate have you seen
those distributions
and those distributions you should have
taken lots of
experiments in order to get a realistic
mean and you've seen it's cute you can
always get
with a single experiment in one of the
ends and
your particular taste uh case when
you'll be running this on a data set
you'll be in one of those cases you
cannot run many times or
you have to run with different hash
algorithms
and that gives you
it ends up with lots of problems and
collisions so it's
the best thing to date which has been
developed is called
hyperlog log it's basically
takes in account problems with
log log and
i'm sorry
i'll be able to show you probably
this is a nice demo this kind guy is
developed for us
which also works uh
in some way similar to previous
structures we've seen it has a
register variables which is a map but
it's not a beepnet it's a
map of values for each incoming
value it takes a hash it chunks a bit of
this
hash and uses this is as the index of a
value in this registers
why it does so it's just basically
trying to bucket
uh different hashes into different beans
so they will have less collisions in
total
and this is very important number also
in calculating accuracy of this message
and then it uses the rest of the
register values which are assigned and
calculates number of
uh in this case will be trailing zero is
plus one
because it's original algorithm which
was published it was it was using plus
one
and then it just sees its register value
is uh zero x-ray here no
trailing zeros but plus one and this
register index gives us
a place where to add this number
and for example here we have three
two living zeros plus one register index
is here
we adding three here and if we run you
will see that
this map became filled with numbers
and they are rising and actually it
calculates
something
nice and it coincides we have a formula
how to
uh extract back from this register value
cardinality of assad that we were
analyzing
this formula is here uh basically it's
some constant to which
uh these smart guys devised by
multiply by square of number of bins to
which we
uh sort our data
which is 64 in our case and then it
summarizes
for all those beans 2 to power of
this register index will store it and
uh so far it says
its error is zero on that set or it
should be
should be lying i think it's not run
till the very end
but the most impressive you can uh
estimate billions of district distinct
values in
like two kilobytes of memory and it was
only two percent error
this is amazing if you just to want to
monitor
what's happening in your data set do
monitoring of your
any streams of data this is
this is brilliant sometimes uh let's
take a look of code
another smart people wrote this code but
you
better be finding that direct
implementation
actually doesn't need to be c it's very
simple and spicen
you can disregard these two values these
are internal parameters of this
algorithm which are just
you see looks like fixed constants
depending on
the size of bet and then
estimated cardinality which basically uh
does that function which i showed you
before which is
harmonic mean it's just a way how to
summarize
it's a type of average how to summarize
values from that
map and some magic corrections
which are well justified in scientific
paper
frankly i haven't got into that i just
trusted them by
empirical evidence in the recitation it
works
and this is how it works we choosing
precisions and it calculates
this example for our precisions uh
how many packets do we need to have for
those bits
and libraries that you are most likely
to use this will be hidden behind the
api similar as it
was in the bloom filter so
you'll be just saying precision that you
want and that's it
or in your estimated cardinality
so
here
i'm sorry i'm losing my own slot to get
slides again
okay i'm sorry i'm going to skip this
because uh
seriously i got caught myself
i can explain you maybe after a break
what was going on there
then how actually adding a number to a
hyperlog log we calculate any number
that came in string
and taking in this case ssh doesn't
matter
it's well good it's quite quick it works
with
string though and gives you back a
string then we
uh determine uh which are first bets
we're getting
the index of this bucket and for the
remaining bits which are
exceeding actually in which we identify
number of
trailing zeros we just chunk them
together identify number of trailing
zeros
and in this bin which was taken from one
part of hash
we just drop this estimator we update it
by
putting their maximum from what we've
seen on this run
against what is already stored there
and here how it works
we're estimating cardinality of uh
1000 uh digits we just
happen to be randomly in this case
sequence
and we are
we were somewhere off sorry what happens
excuse me it's we are driving we're just
taking a sample of 1000 digits with a
number of
one billion
or one hundred million from zero
i'm very sorry i should take a break
sorry for a few minutes right now
should do you have any questions to
previous materials that we have
yes please
probabilistic part that uh doesn't
guarantee you don't have a guarantee
that similar elements are uh leading to
the same hash and you neither don't have
a guarantees the different elements are
leading to
not don't have a collision so this is
was a probabilistic element to this
um
you
so
okay i caught up already with what's
happening here why i didn't
get a number which i wanted because i
updated hyperlog log twice
so here just it happens that
after defining a function
this add new which adds element to
hyperloglog
i already run once a code which
populates
it and i threw into
1000 elements and i got cardinality
estimation of 94
000 which is underestimation and then
i'm just happening to be
throwing again another 100 number
thousand numbers which
actually together with those up to 200
000
and that's why i'm getting 190
000 which is just 4 000 short from the
real number of
uh unique elements which might not be
this number might be even closer to real
value because
if you remember i'm drawing random
numbers and they are
happen to be sometimes the same as the
same ones
so this cardinality of the set
will be less than number
numbers i have added to it finally
i'm very sorry for getting lost right
now
so we a bit shy on
on this and we still can update it
back to the second to the following
structure
so we calculated number of elements but
this is
not enough we
sometimes we want to know actually how
many times we've seen each element
which is uh interesting thing and uh if
you
consider is that basically you want to
build a frequency list for a stream
if you have infinite number of distinct
elements most likely you
you won't be able to but if you are
trying to
build the distribution of where your
users are coming from from which
countries are coming from
and in this case you just know countries
are limited we have 200 countries
let's just build the frequency histogram
but what will happen if you want to
build this for
user agents which are not actually
limited and you can have anything there
including both and everyday new version
of your user agent
so we can use this thing actually this
is a bit
it's again a register map as in
uh hyperloop log we
have rows which are getting some values
from different hashes
and we have widths actually it's adapts
for each of
this row and we're taking a value which
we want to
uh store or
later calculate cardinality take a hash
which corresponds to each row in the
structure and with this hash
yields us index in this row
where to look and if we are
inserting value into count means catch
we just
plus one in each element we're doing the
same we did in blood filter but bloom
filter we
were using only one row and we were
setting
once in this case we're rising them we
every time
adding plus one and then later when we
want to calculate
uh actually what was the frequency for
this element
after we're running for several days
analyzing our log files
we're just taking minimum of these cells
this element addresses us to and
because of hash collisions uh we're
trying to underestimate
other elements being also storing some
some data into these cells
and we want to be sure that we will take
the minimum one because
the minimum one will be the most the
closest to
the value of our data as we were
accounting
however there is still a problem uh
can't mean sketch will be overestimating
because
maybe one element has
collide on this cell another collided in
this cell
and one more collided on that cell and
it have risen
for our element we're trying right now
to estimate it's using this cardinality
there are boundaries on its accuracy
and they are depending on a total
number of elements of on your basically
width of your mattress
and number of your hash codes and should
you use any library
you will have all the control over these
elements quite
quite nicely so
freaking eat item stats
so this is another example which
uh actually is priced in implementation
of uh
um of a sketch which i slightly
simplified
in order to fit in the slide but it
doesn't fit
it takes in this case parameters which
you have to calculate
directly through those formulas
originals
and that's some control
then it calculates for you the uh
bits of mattress the number of
dimensions
and the nice interesting things that i
already in this
class i included number elements i want
to sample
and i want to get top
10 elements which are the most frequent
ones
if you remember at the very beginning we
were discussing how to get 10 random
elements from the infinite stream
now the problem is how to get the top 10
most frequent element of the stream and
to show you some stats so this is will
be
just a slightly tiny addition to
count min sketch this is an update
function
which basically takes element in and
also
a parameter which says how many
seen how many times you've seen it it
takes
a hash function we defined
in initialization of this class
and hash functions yield the several
different
parameters one of which defines the row
into which we
calculate it's a dimension on row
and hash function is actually column
value
and then we're getting column and just
going into row and column and
incrementing it
with the increment which is in our case
always will be one
and there is another magic function
which does update heap
which will try to look if this element
is the most
frequent in the whole table and if it
does it will be stored
into our frequent list so
well just it's awkwardly written but
it's quite
straightforward it uses this heap queue
in order to optimize
uh its performance
but basically all it does it looks if
its element happened to be
one of the top highest in estimates
and checks if it's already in the set
and gets rid of
elements it doesn't want to if we got it
and
get element we want to get cardinality
for each element
we're doing exactly the same we did in
update value but in this case we just
take a minimum of all cells
we've been writing to and here is a
hash function so quite simple
we initialize it we store our element we
got the element
it says its cardinality is one
and well there is only one k element
so let's go back into that flip coins
it's longest run
zeros it's a very big trial of 500
trials
thousand coins flips an inch here is
this distribution
and so let's uh store all of those
and trying to see what's the
distribution of those leading
zeros so basically i'm trying to
find the mean of this distribution
and i said that i want to store
top five elements or top six elements
and they are coinciding with elements
the highest
cardinalities the largest number of
zeros
continuously in that out in that set
somewhere around eight which is
which coincides with this histogram plot
and if you can see that we have tiny
number for 12 which are happen to be
here and we have nothing
for longer tail so it estimated number
of uh
occurrences of those sequences of zeros
good so we can build a frequent item set
popular browser agents on fly from any
data stream
so what's next and this is more about
approximation solutions and this is
about hacks it's
less scientific but more practical
and machine learning if you all heard
about
you have to deal with preparing
your data for for training
encoding data cleaning data finding
which data
fields are uh important
trying to evaluate how they correlate
with each other basically trying to
reduce the cardinality of your
data sets you're trying to get rid of as
many features as possible in order to
train your
algorithm quicker and more accurate
there are different reasons for that
there is a trick for though for that
though
you can take all features and hash them
and yeah take the hash and use the cache
as a single feature
so what it does it actually it's very
simple it's a projection of all your
features into
uh into dot in multi-dimensional space
which is this hash vector
and this is dirty heck
dirty hack it most likely in practical
you
will be able to find better way for
constructing features for your training
and algorithms
but sometimes it does its work and in
particular people are using that
for training on in nlp for doing very
rough tasks
so we taken hash and for each words that
actually yield us a hash we
uh add a number into this vector and we
use this vector as a single value for
classification for entering this is uh
andrew clegg been explaining us how
we've been doing this and
also he showed us how actually to
visualize and
if you remember we were talking about
cassand distance so
you if you'd be comparing me against
somebody else you can design all the
features how are different
each feature will have its own access
that length tall
weight and if we to put the point which
represents me on that access
basically a vector from starting to this
point
and the other person and in order to
avoid comparison of different features
together
there is a very grounded method we're
just
measuring cosine distance between those
two vectors
this very classical approach and what's
tricky here and this is all called
hash it's a loc
it's basically on local sensitive
hashing in this case
as well that is called hashing trick and
machine learning
we are able to approximate this distance
between two vectors
as just bit distance between hashes
so it's hamming bitwise hamming distance
we just calculate how many permutations
we need to make in one
uh hash in order to get another one
basically a number of different bits
and this gives you very accurate
uh distance and you can just assume that
just relying on this you can then put
some hyper planes in your
space or you can see that those hashes
somehow are located somewhere nearby
and classify your data especially if
you're using locality sensitive hashing
which are essential in this way okay and
to finalize you
don't need to write everything by
yourself there are
smart people who are doing this uh
frankly all of them are in academia and
those projects some of them like
about they are quite academic and the
very last one which is actually
i'll be advertising i like it it's still
in
zero and one alpha yeah but it looks
very promising
so what these databases do
these databases implement those tricks
and
they hide them behind queer languages
which happen to be sql queries
and they enable you to deal with samples
of data they pre-sample data for you
and this is very important because
sampling data is much trickier than
actually i just explained you
when you'll go to depths because your
data
is likely to be skewed you're not likely
to be
always see the same data you will have
some cycles
so this blink db is comparing itself
against well hadoop and
spark and spark whiz caching without
caching
and blink dp was one person terror what
is one percent error if you are dealing
with
terabytes of data it's like nothing
i have to say that this is a
log scale so this means that actually
between this number of
bling db it's a query response time in
seconds
we are 100 times you know 10 times
better than
the nearest algorithm
and yeah and something like
100 times better than hadoop without
caching
so how does it work and how it looks
like it's like
it's magic you say sql query and tell me
that
i want to get this average for last two
seconds
oh i'm sorry for in two seconds so just
constraining it by time and it will
reply you in two seconds at most
or you are uh trying to
get a bound on the confidence
what's happening behind here this
database is good only for aggregates
you would not be using it for querying
get me element number seven
no this is it'll be wrong database
completely
but if you're to do any data analysis
any cubes if you're familiar
familiar with all those tableau analysis
this is like
magic when you can just get
approximate value because nobody in
business development actually cares
about that accuracy
they will they won't notice they're just
gonna okay data losses somewhere
but you'll get in two seconds reply
and actually that works despite it being
version zero one alpha
it's it has limited uh
number of functions you can call
all those functions are having
well some of those data structures
hidden behind and there is
a structure of one very large
scale how it how it will try to organize
the data
basically it has very sophisticated
sample
module which splits data
in uniform sample in order to do
preliminary lookups
uh even before getting into the exact
transfer to the query you
asked this database we will take a look
in a small uniform sample and plan its
query on that
which data structure to need and which
parameters for the data structure to
select
and then just because it's already
sampled in a very nice way
it has guarantees over these samples it
can actually works only with parts of
your data
and it happened to be nicely distributed
across cluster
and it can interrupt itself at any time
or when the confidence bound will be
reached
and also just because you can get
confidence bounds limited
it can only deal with you can be fine
with dealing with in-memory samples
these samples which are uh they call
this stratified or
basically uh they're trying to get as
fair as possible sample for
each particular case and uh
i think this is it references uh
this is a very great book to read if you
would to have
any desire to follow
i would really encourage you to look
through the context of this book
just just read content
for you to know where to look later if
you have any need
in those approaches and
what's to take out so this is a nice
slide which was presented by
ilyakatsov and he was trying to
visualize
what the benefits of having the whole
big data set
40 megabyte which is i actually frankly
would say it's very small for these
problems don't
play with database with data sets that
are
if your data set can fit in memory
without any problem you don't need any
probabilistic data structures
it will be much quicker for you to fit
in the memory and this is my
first summary know also
what sacrifice control the errors at
first actually i missed
know when not to use it don't use it if
you don't need to
frankly but in some cases it's amazing
because
here's the memory consumption for other
data structures we were discussing
frequencies of the top hundred elements
from the data structure
we were discussing exact membership
cardinality we didn't discuss it's
basically
restoring table of all elements and
exact
as you can imagine by some dictionary
membership
query was for presenter or bloom filter
bloom furniture takes a bit of memory if
you want to control errors nicely
cardinality estimation
it's a hyperloglog in our case we were
discussing
cardinality estimation with another it's
a linear counter
it's basically less efficient and i
not sure if you would have any need to
use those algorithms if you will have
special case for zeros
and what's here an exact frequency to
compare if we
to use probabilistic data structures for
frequency or
like this or exact frequencies exact
membership or bloom filter membership
and a lot of things
um always control errors don't know
no to using this message if you are not
confident in your
if you use algorithms which don't give
you boundaries
precise boundaries unexpected boundaries
of your
uh error you just
should be running an empirical
experiment and
look at the divorced performance they
deliver
and just see how those results are
distributed
and yeah know that you're sacrificing
with your accuracy and it's not always
good when
you're dealing with 14 megabyte of data
okay thank you